moi quand je fais l'Américain je suis un
peu classe je fais comme ça
interview sans la bouche
[Musique]
Jean Paul
interview sur la bouche attention ne dis
rien vous êtes dans une soirée Claude
Berry vous vous salue on vous appelant
Jean-Pierre rive vous êtes obligé de
sourire parce que c'est Claude Berry
vous seriez comme
soirée Nicolas Sarkozy arrive vous salue
vous parle vous félicite un photographe
arrive faites quelle tête sur la photo
Jean-Paul à ce moment là une sublime
gonzesse entre ne regarde que vous vous
êtes inaccessible faites quelle tête
inaccessible mais pas trop
inaccessible mais pas trop mais pas trop
inaccessible inaccessible je suis
inaccessible mais pas trop pas trop
discret
à la
Nicole Kidman arrive dans cette soirée
où il y a Claude Berry déjà et Nicolas
Sarkozy
et alors elle vous voit comme ça
Jean-Paul
vous faites vous l'avez pas reconnu
c'est le nouveau comique c'est Alain
Delon fait quelle tête
je mets des caisses dans la vie
Jean-Paul Jean-Pierre Guérin le
producteur de Gilles Lescaut vous
raconte vos débuts dans la série il vous
propose de revenir dans la série Julie
Lescaut à un million de francs l'épisode
pizza
vous prenez votre voiture vous allez
prendre un dernier verre au cost et là
vous lui dites Nicole contrairement à ce
que tout le monde croit je ne suis pas
d'Oran je suis américain
moi quand je fais l'Américain je suis un
peu classe je fais comme ça
j'envole vous quittez la soirée avec
tour
vous en avez marre d'être avec ça
vous allez vous allez au Coste et vous
rencontrez Alain Chabat et une colle
Kidman qui sont en train de prendre un
dernier verre il fait l'Américain
vous vous asseyez vous êtes là tous les
trois ou un coup et d'un seul coup
Ophélie Winter arrive je suis bonjour
Ophélie
je peux pas parler et là elle me demande
pourquoi c'est un truc à cardissons
normalement excuse-moi et pour être sûr
de ne rien rater de innarditude
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu